so if you could stab one of them who
would you stab them I [__] stab all
of them because they do it bad
but then they they go oh you but then
they also give me credit and they're
like dude you're the first and I'm like
I know so give me your [__] money
[Music]
all right y'all there has been some
[__] violence in the food blogging
World violence finally
does get into like a YouTube mukbang
fight thing I think she'd win like she's
pretty feisty she's pretty feisty huh
she also like three feet seven though
like what if uh she's low to the ground
she go with a knife yeah that's what I'm
saying bite your ankles and [__] clean
cuts only and she's Vietnamese so she
got fired I bet she don't know how to do
it too and still keep her Jordans clean
food blogger stabbed to death by rival
influencer while live streaming from
Nepal oh it's [__] dirty this is
spicy that's like Tupac and Biggie style
but Nepalese food vlogger Style with
[__] knives on a live stream why do
they got beef with each other
I've seen it happen like let's say a new
restaurant open yeah and that restaurant
um has a special drink and you want to
be the first one to show the lavender
coffee you know oh yeah and you're
fighting over to post first dude I've
seen some crazy stuff that's [__]
ridiculous
you're on the for you page now yeah
everyone wants to be on the for you page
and that's gonna launch their career but
then again do it eventually over time
everyone [__] goes to that spot they
always get the they just but then you're
the first everyone else who does it then
when they look up that they bite you I
guess yeah it's attributed to you yeah
but dude don't stab somebody over that
huh or stab somebody over that huh dude
people fighting now you you can't run a
food blog in jail bro oh you know what
I'm saying you can do one of those like
bunk mate videos yeah but the food's not
gonna be as good you want ice cream give
you some coffee creamer I'm gonna make
some ice cream
who would I stab in the dance who would
you if you could dance if you could
stand stabs why are you looking at Ryan
like that dude all right D-Trix
what do you do well it's like you had a
dance move but someone else dropped it
first yeah how upset would you be and
that dance move launched their career
you know what that means that means they
watched in practice so that other
person's a Kinja yup whoa so which other
Kingdom would you have to stab
out of all the kinjas who's the most
bitey yeah who copies it all the time
yeah who's the copiest Joe I'm not Kinja
yet don't be saying that yeah yeah not
yet just not yet
I just want to be asked so I can be like
nah I'm already Quest
if you just you
can't just be a move it has to be like
the whole combo to the whole song but
you know what I mean all those uh all
those uh dancers that got upset with
Charlie what's your name the girl from
Twitter oh yeah Charlie DML everyone
who's pissed at her because they just
took other people's moves but they got
popular dude
that's complicated yeah that's social
dances the whole point of that is to
like do what everybody else is doing
people are just mad because her audience
is bigger that's it I feel like
everyone's always everybody feel
everybody's [__] man we [__]
originating the [__] Asian mom [__]
in the [__] making fun of Asian [__]
that was us everybody else try to [__]
it and you know so if you could stab one
of them who would you stab them I
[__] stab all of them because they do
it bad
but then they they go oh you but then
they also give me credit and they're
like dude you're the first and I'm like
I know so give me your [__] money
how they do is they compliment you and
then they do it yeah that's like that's
the hard way they compliment you first
and then they steal no they get really
big and then they go but you're the
first on I'm like I'm like no I know no
but you're successful so what would you
do if somebody copied your exact same
[__] mortgage rate [__] for that one
day for that post and they were dancing
in front of the house the same way you
did same music you know what but then
she got more likes if they like someone
actually copied a post so we had a
lawyer send a season assists if it's
like a post that's legitimate that I
know I came up with someone took our
ultimate mortgage guide and just changed
their information when they got a letter
from us right away you wouldn't stab
them
you don't mind my dancing by the way I
try to do the Chris Farley thing like
the fat guy dancing that's my that's
your brand yeah that's my brand what if
I steal it Batman
little suit that's what I think when
these people laugh but then if someone
else did that hey it would be hard what
if he's like fatter than you though and
they and he got more views it would I'd
probably trip him sometimes I don't see
some this this is I [__] stab and
deceased oh [__] that's right okay so a
popular Chinese street food blogger
known was stabbed uh or a known food
blogger was stabbed to death while live
streaming from Nepal in a bizarre attack
wow carried out by a rival influencer
allegedly Chinese National
age 37 was arrested December 4th on
suspicion of killing Gan solo John wait
believe there's [__] two Chinese
[__] people fighting a nipple that's
dude fighting the nipples
and injuring also a 32 year old leech
who's on uh somebody who was with damn
it was murder yeah but what was the the
violent knife attack took place Sunday
afternoon at the crowded Indra chalk
Market in the capital Kathmandu
um and shocking video shows gun who is
known online as fatty goes to Africa
broadcasting himself live walking and
laughing with a pair of Friends when the
scene is suddenly interrupted by a
series of distressing high-pitched
screams followed by wild shaking before
the screen goes black oh my God a later
recording shows a visibly dazed gun
sitting in the middle of the street
covered in blood while another person
believed to be Fang can be heard
swearing at him in Chinese so what was
he doing was he doing like a mukbang
live streaming like eating skewers and
[__] and then the dude comes up and
starts shanking on me [__] basically
damn are you guys down to see some
[__] oh hell yeah but not for
pleasure oh I want I wanted to see the
video but I'm down with photos too
that's sad dude that's so sad dude what
did he get him in his neck so in his uh
chest and in his gut whoa
like over a food blog I know bro like
lame is [__] let me show you the uh the
arrest what if it's like we're just
imagine oh my God the next one what if
we're just imagining them eating food
but like you know what they do right
they actually tell stories when they eat
food so they might have been [__]
going back and forth talking mad [__]
while they eat like a Shaolin ball or
something they might be eating that [__]
and be like man [__] this [__]
you know so the first photo you could
see him just kind of sitting there in
shock like calling out for help so
onlookers people with phones and stuff
like that this is him lying down he was
rushed to the hospital and ended up
dying there that's sad dude from
injuries to his chest into his gut and
this right here let me see that
[__] sad man this is the Rival
influencer
oh come on this guy looks like a gang
member dude what is he doing yeah he
doesn't look like a social media looks
like a villain already with that jacket
on is this no stuff with tissue yeah he
must have got [__] up he looks like a
turtle dude yeah
that's what looks like a turd he looks
like the kind of guy that's like and I
would do it again yeah and I would eat
him the other guy looks like an actual
food vlogger this guy looks like a
pervert it's like a nightclub it looks
like he goes out to nightclub yeah like
an idiot dude yeah what does he that's
crazy it's probably jealousy because the
other guy knows all the good foods and
then this guy he [__] rates like
Capri Suns or something lame and [__]
and he doesn't get any views
so that other guy probably roasted his
ass like man it's fully he ain't even
got enough money to review good [__] now
you're [__] reviewing an Oreo cookie
or whatever and it's like everyone can
get that and that's where the Rivalry
started happening and they started
fighting over that [__] it's like
watching that that movie National
Treasure with uh Nicholas Cage every
time he tries to discover something
someone's chasing behind him to get it
and then they're gonna kill him once he
gets it
Fang who actually lived in Nepal held a
grudge against guns stemming from uh
multiple unspecified disputes and
unresolved debts apparently deaths John
used the social media platform to
introduce his nearly five million
followers in China to the food and
culture of foreign countries they'll
just beat his ass man what's with the
[__] kill shots that's crazy just
because he got to a Food Spot before him
that's ridiculous that's crazy I mean no
matter what it's about why the vital
organ [__] especially with online beef
like that's like public you know what I
mean it's not that serious bro you're
gonna be with somebody you want to
especially if you're willing to go down
like he was willing to go down he was
like I'm gonna go to jail what if he
just mixed up his fake knives with this
real knife drawer that does happen
sometimes because your grandma's gonna
get the fake knives to scare him kind of
like Alec Baldwin but then they gave him
the real you know 30 of stabbings happen
that way because really yeah you mixed
up the fake one on the real one they
thought they had the toy one where it
goes in when you put it in yeah and
they're like whoa there's too much
at any time it's like accidentally mixed
up and there's like blood you're still
not sure so you have to try it two or
three more times and make sure you got
the wrong knife oh my God that other guy
looks like he works as like a low-level
Russian gangster
oh yeah yeah for real
that's so stupid man I can't believe
that I feel like internet beef is so
funny so [__] in it it is so [__] but
then this [__] got so real that I'm just
like I can't even compute because that's
like imagine if makeup industry dudes
started like shooting each other
they're like yo you stole my [__]
mascara like like formula dude like you
[__] release this [__] and I was like
now I came up with the first [__] and
he's like and the eye shadow that you
[__] did well [__] you too and then
they started shooting each other imagine
if that I think that's way better than
[__] this dude well it always just
makes me sad that someone who wants to
kill someone else will go with the I
guess the um we'll go with the dumbest
way to do it yeah like at least leave
behind an unsolvable crime this is like
you obviously did it yeah if you want to
kill someone that bad put a little
thought into it and they were like live
streaming yeah like make it make
yourself harder to catch at least if you
were a food blogger would you kind of
calm like relax for a while let them let
the let the dust settle like stop going
out there yeah and doing food blogging
for a little while
I think I think I might especially if
you're in the same circles as them
this might be one of the probably the
first food blog related murder you would
think of food blog related murder would
be a poisoned piece of food
the loads right in front of you because
at the end of the day like you everybody
got to eat every day you know what I
mean it's not like uh so many people are
going to like hot important nights
because you're you're blogging about the
import scene and there's only so many
events like food blogging is like you
[__] eat every day there's
restaurants open every single day
there's like really a lot of places you
can go if you want to be out somebody's
territory or whatever there's a lot of
world around you know you know how to
kill somebody in the food blogger world
you guys ever seen Miss Doubtfire
I remember the paprika scene oh yeah
that's how you get rid of them
[__] dude you go
let's pick a little paprika bro in the
food blog world all you gotta do is make
a fake account like you're this new
person starting a new restaurant or
making a new snack say hey would you
like to do Brandy with me I'm coming out
with this new food would you like to
film yourself eating it eventually send
the food over dude goes hey I'm trying
this new food that someone sent
delete everything never existed duh easy
how many times have you done that Ryan
why stab when you have ideas like that
yeah [__] rat poison on top of food
if I had to do it how would I do it I
would be I would do Pho restaurant in
the broth
that's sacred and you could be like fuss
so good it'll kill you
[Music]